you reap out of a flying bus and are now
soaring through the strangely purple
skyline above a cartoonish island your
fingers clasped tightly around the
handles of your hand glider which is an
ironic we made of candy
you're dressed head-to-toe in superhero
esque armor eyes glowing
there's also angel wings protruding from
your back as the tilted towers rooftops
get closer and you anticipate your first
move your head swivels as you realize
you're surrounded by people who want to
kill you John wick to the left tomato
head to the right you're breaking into a
building through the roof your
excavation tool of choice is an odd
combination of a plunger fused with a
katana trying to find some way to stay
alive your feet hit the floor and you
quickly open a glimmering treasure chest
in the hopes of finding a weapon welcome
to fourth a fortnight is taking the
world by storm but it didn't happen
overnight the game was locked away in
development for almost seven years after
it was announced back in 2011 the
developer Epic Games was working on a
brand new game engine called Unreal
Engine 4 in order to build a game to
rival Minecraft the community's
incredible creativity has taken
minecraft in two places we never could
have imagined there are plenty of
unforeseen difficulties associated with
building a brand new game engine
especially if you want it to rival one
of the world's most popular games and
that along with epics desire to make
fortnight feel like a living organism
with constant updates and additions
slowed down its development in a big way
for tonight's initial concept was simple
you were going to get to build
structures just like in Minecraft but in
fortnight you'd be building a base to
stave off monsters called a husks at
night and survive the storm
for two in-game weeks it was going to be
everything that was popular in 2011
squished together and blasted onto your
television screen from your call sense
by 2014 epic had a prototype version of
the game ready for release and the
Unreal Engine 4 was slowly being refined
but was held back to further smooth out
the gameplay the vision that epic had
for this player versus environment
iteration of the game is pretty similar
to the save the world version we see now
that kind of moment that moment that
makes people cheer even if they're not
playing is precisely what fortnight ago
by June 2017 fortnight was finally ready
for the public but the hype had died
down significantly since its initial
announcement six years ago it was crisp
colorful and combined the building
assets of Minecraft with a shooter like
Halo or Gears of War just like epic
wanted guns 4x4 structures and zombies
it had it all but the game were less
stripped on its way out of tomato town
what was taking off though was a
different game format the players just
couldn't get enough of battle royale
Battle Royale games were taking the
gaming world by storm but they began
mostly as minecraft mods that were
stylized round pop-culture storylines
like The Hunger Games by fans of both
genres the format is simple contestants
are all trapped in a remote location and
must fight one another by any means
necessary until only one winner is left
standing
I may be the first non mod battle royale
game that had significant success was
h1z1 this was the first battle royale
brainchild from Brendon player unknown
green an Irish photographer and web
designer turned battle royale developer
who had been working on mods for a while
he would then go on to create his own
project player unknowns battlegrounds
and then last year Blue Hole contacted
me from Korea and said we love what you
don't want about royale game we'd like
you to lead a team and make your own
battle royale and pop G was born at pop
G launched in early access during March
of 2017 and it's hard to overstate just
how groundbreaking it was funnily enough
the games developer blue hole utilized
epics Unreal Engine 4 in order to ensure
the game could handle the studio's new
100 person bloodbath yes that same
engine being used to build fortnight pub
G averaged over a hundred thousand
viewers at a time in August and
September of 2017 and even attracted
eSports attention from the likes of ESL
this is gonna be massing they're gonna
be running into each other any second
now they're just steps behind you're
gonna see the bullets in the back in
there
the boots coming into spring comes out
Guddu up taking them down but it's gonna
be enough Battle Royale
was in and with 8 million copies sold
that August and 10 million that
September people couldn't get enough of
it my Amin off the ship so after an
eternity and development fortnight made
its debut in the summer of 2017 as a
bridesmaid while the belle of the ball
of G and all eyes on in on September 26
2017 Epic Games made a move to keep up
with pub G they simply put the world's
biggest game into their game big a
fortnight the biggest shot in the arm
you could give a game in 2017
they added a battle royale mode of their
own pub G may have been the first battle
royale game to take off but when Epic
Games dropped fortnight's battle royale
mode it became clear that the genre had
yet to hit its ceiling
not only did fortnight be pub G to
console but its battle royale mode was
free to play while pub G's cost $30
and unlike pub G or night offered an
irreverent playful style that appealed
to gamers of all ages
Battle Royale is inspired by an
undoubtedly gruesome eret of but for
networks hard to just oppose the grim
fate of that island with the kind of
bouncy bubbly and bombastic gameplay
you'd expect from a Disney Pixar movie
after all what could be more fun than
wearing your bunny costume into battle
according to epic games where they broke
hub G's concurrent players record in
February 2018 hitting 3.4 million
concurrence and Amazon's twitch thoughts
March traffic surge 40% thanks to
fortnight the most watched game in
twitch history the Battle Royale bubble
has burst and fortnight has been crowned
master of the genre at least Fernet
between April 22nd and May 22nd of 2018
which viewers watched 139 million three
hundred and thirty three thousand two
hundred and sixteen hours a fortnight
and the game has quite literally become
a cultural phenomenon did you get season
four already time so needless to say the
relationship between Epic Games and
pubsey developers Blue Hole has become a
little awkward since epic has now taken
their Unreal Engine and built their own
battle royale game around it as a result
on May 29th hub G filed a copyright
violation lawsuit asking the court to
decide whether fortnight was a copy of
pub G but despite this looming lawsuit
fortnight continues to leap into the
mainstream like the game just ate a hot
rock it's all over social media pretty
much all my friends yeah you can
literally walk on the street you can see
someone playing on their phone and
everyone is talking about it I know that
I know the game I've heard references to
it online people getting into trouble
playing it too much girlfriends and
boyfriends you know I've played once
and I got number 25 so I'm pretty proud
it up that's it and I have this teacher
who place it and talks about it with my
classmates for day like they play it in
there like talking about a / class so
it's kind of annoying in game what's
most different about fortnight is its
pace it's a game obviously number one
optimized and that is why its popularity
is just like street I can try it yeah
you'll love it when you die you can get
back in the queue within seconds and be
right back in the action it offers
normal gunfights
building fights that turn into editing
fights in jet pack fights among others
oh yes is that the only thing more
limitless than the fun is the capacity
for skillful game player it's battle
royale mode was released it took
fortnight just three short months to
show comparable average twitch
viewership numbers to pub G by February
it had completely eclipsed tits
predecessor with an average of ninety
seven thousand nine hundred and for
viewers to pub jeez sixty-four thousand
six hundred and fifty four as of May
fortnight has taken over twitch then the
game is averaging more than 178,000
viewers at any given time completely
dismantling its competition you jump in
need to experience the whole story for
an episode start finished because it's a
game and you get to feel like you're
part of something I think that that is
massive for for viewership this game
this is the League of Legends killing so
what was the breaking point
well it came in the form of a 26 year
old former Halo Pro turned streamer
on March 15th Tyler ninja Blevins
massacred the twitch individual
streaming record when he played a
fortnight's quads match with rappers
Drake and Travis Scott and Pittsburgh
Steelers wide receiver juju Smith
Schuester haha but not a lot of supplies
brief I mean ah baby I'm ready as soon
as the boy doneness touched down on
four-night Island the barrier to entry
to video games of the streaming fell and
fortnight became a household name I
think that that kind that's I think that
that literal one match with Drake made
it okay for everyone to play video games
it's not like gaming wasn't big before
but in that moment became mainstream in
a way that few games have fortnight is
free-to-play and accessible across
consoles PCs and iOS mobile devices it's
the online game that has fans at a
frenzy yeah I didn't start playing until
Drake started playing so you came on
this one that night ninja broke the
twitch viewership record with more than
six hundred and thirty thousand
concurrent viewers just a few weeks
later late in April he broke his own
record with Ninja Vegas his very own the
event peaked at around six hundred and
seventy nine thousand concurrent's I I
can't even imagine what that even looks
like if you saw how many people were
terrifying oh yeah after these two
massive streaming splashes ninja stream
hook over the twitch world as of May
23rd 2018 ninja was averaging more than
a hundred and twenty five thousand
viewers every day while he streamed he
finished April more
popular on social media and the likes of
Cristiano Ronaldo and Shaquille O'Neal
for tonight was faulted into the living
room small talk zeitgeist and ninja was
right there with it
so in a world of this
this and this Red Sox pitcher David
price at Thursday that video games are
not the cause of his carpal tunnel
syndrome but stressed he will not play
the popular game fortnight in the team's
clubhouse again quote to avoid the
distraction it has already caused and
for what's the next step for for them
well in a traditional sense it's busy
esports previous games that have
splashed into relevancy have tried to
strengthen their foothold on the gaming
community by branching their programming
into competitive events major eSports
organizations like Team solomid and faze
clan have already made big commitments
by signing players and building
fortnight teams in a reaction to the
game's massive popularity in theory this
incentivizes players to log hours and
compete to make a career out of the game
but for tonight's a little different the
games aren't the long team focus logs
that you'll find in League of Legends or
dota 2 they're snappy and quick and it's
not like you can hold a camera over the
top of the entire island not to mention
the logistical issues associated with
putting a hundred rates and
professionals in a room together but
fortnight and epic games are making a
run at making eSports a possibility on
May 21st
epic announced that they would be
putting up 100 million dollars towards
490 sports between 2018 and 2019
looks like daddy's coming out of
retirement since then during the
fortnight pro-am at e3 epic also
announced where that money would be
going the fortnight World Cup qualifying
for the four night World Cup will be
based on merit and epic will not be
selling teams or franchises and we won't
allow third party leads to do so either
this event will spread that 100 million
dollars over a number of different
online and land qualifying events all
over the world this will all culminate
in the World Cups for which details have
not yet been announced before for
tonight even has a competitive game mode
they're willing to come out and say
fortnight is here the stand just a day
later epic announced fortnight's
involvement in e3 where they hosted a
three million dollar charity pro-am at
the gaming showcase featuring the likes
of ninja myth marshmallow and NBA star
Paul George ninja and marshmallow were
crowned champions at the fortnight
pro-am and as he raised his golden
pickaxe with a peak viewership of 1.5
million watching online ninjas
stranglehold as the king of fortnight
tightened
so fortnight has built itself into this
towering structure of commercial success
and absolute fan obsession there are
enemies on all sides competing games and
critics armed with bougie bombs and pump
shotguns there are aiming game
references showing up all over popular
culture your parents know what fortnight
is your teacher spends their night
chasing victory Royales and your social
media feeds are flooded with highlights
memes and fortnight players busting a
move
[Music]
it wasn't that long ago that we thought
pub G was the next big thing that the
rest of our gaming lives would be spent
on that post-apocalyptic wasteland will
fortnight become the understudy just as
quickly or are we bound to that Island
building ramps up to the sky riding
rockets to get that jaw-dropping hill
and in leaping off that launch pad to
avoid the storm and fly into fortnight's
limitless future thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]